Not today, you guys.
Not today.
I'm so tired.
When are you like, don't keep, when are you not tired?
That's the secret, guys.
I'm always tired.
I was, I had, I know, that's right.
I can't be late if I start a meeting.
minute early wow i know you guys are looking i know i see
you guys i know you guys have the timer website that that
pinpoints exactly how much how oh my gosh my brain how that
counts the seconds of of exactly past five if i'm late and
be and you guys are gonna be like look see she's
zero point uh one two seconds late i know you guys you're
gonna be like some olympic timer shit you're like check the
replay check the slow-mo jay damn jokie back at it with the
earliest stream then you're gonna super chat terminate it
thank you it's gonna be like the fucking olympic referees
and be like check the timer guys check it she's three
nanoseconds late punishment punish her right now
anyway guys um hello everyone um i am still suffering i
don't know how else to put this but i am i'm still going
through it still catching up to past stokie's deeds i'm
still still fucking trying to power through it'll all be
revealed soon It'll all be revealed soon, and then you'll
all understand.
What was I going to say?
I see, remember, okay, for those who were watching
yesterday's Twitch stream, or was watching the VOD, I said
that I finally see the light to the tunnel.
So that was a lie.
They also saw the light to the tunnel, and then piled dirt
on it.
So now, so I feel like...
not to dig for the light of the tunnel uh so the light is
like further away now uh so today i found out the light will
now be further away uh so and so it's not i guess i guess
that's not over for me yet it's not over back to the grind
don't keep back to the grind uh so close.
Now I don't know when the light will end.
Smokey, like when the light will come up.
Smokey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for ruining my sleep schedule last night.
Big break.
No problem.
If I can't sleep, you're not sleeping too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, that wasn't a light.
It was an incoming train.
Now I'm concerned what happened to the train.
It was a train.
What the funny happened to the train.
Today might not be a super long stream because I have a lot
of behind.
I know I keep saying that.
When will you stop having a lot behind the scenes stuff to
do?
But you'll all understand.
You guys will understand soon.
I don't know when.
But soon it'll all be revealed.
And then you'll be like, oh, that's why.
so i might not be a super long stream today because i have
uh i have some stuff i have to do behind the scenes um but
yeah i just wanted to let you guys know that uh what game
are we playing today we are playing scritchy scratchy is
apparently a scratch and win roguelite which has two of my
favorite things like gambling in game i actually never
gambled in real life before well i mean there's gotcha i
don't count gotcha and stuff i was like me technically it is
gambling but it's like gambling for kids um like baby's
first gambum um but i've never okay that's a lot i've done
scratch and win but that's because like that was those that
was like my parents but i've never willingly gambled like
irl before like like at a casino i've never been to a casino
before um so never done slots machines or play cards or
whatever the fuck or do like roulette or all that shit i've
never actually gambled in real life in game video game
however however we're talking about in game for make believe
money make believe money not the gamma website make believe
money uh virtual currency that has no relations to real life
money
But yes, it combines two of my favorite things.
Pretend gambling, make-believe imaginary gambling that has
no real-life consequences, and lottery tickets.
Oh, I'm sorry, that's also again, I'm sorry.
And and Rogue, like, sorry, I was like, gambling and
gambling, my two favorite things.
I meant make-believe gambling and and Rogue likes.
So let's get into it.
Dragoon eats cloud.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's really, oh yeah, I was going to talk, I said I was
going to talk about this, uh, yesterday, but I post, I
can't, I post a picture of dad because he's back, by the
way.
Dad's back.
Um, and you know, he doesn't, he didn't look so happy in his
little kennel, but, uh, there was like, when I posted it, I
was looking for someone to say post this reply because my
comment was uh jailed for his crimes so i you know i you
know obviously a lot of people made some really funny
comments about it funny replies and why what i realized was
that nobody said this one and the reason why i can't post
the picture like show you guys the picture on stream was
because i was waiting for someone because people were like
What did he do?
Free him.
He's innocent.
So surprised.
After 160 replies.
Nobody said indecent exposure.
Because I thought it'd be a funny reply.
I legit thought it'd be funny.
So it's so indecent.
We have laws for a reason.
reason.
I, I, what?
We have rules.
We have laws.
I didn't even notice until like after I posted it and I was
like, oh shit.
I after I post because I was like, oh that's a cute funny
photo.
And after I posted it, I then noticed it.
I was like, oh fuck, okay.
Maybe someone will make a funny reply.
and then because people were like why did because in my head
I was like oh shit people are gonna be like why the fuck did
you take a picture of your dog exposing himself and then I
was like fuck I can't I posted it already it's too late it's
already out there on the internet but then nobody noticed it
and then I was like you know I didn't know what post in
decent exposure like
anyway let's go play scritchy scratchy uh my my make-believe
gamba.
Alright, where the fuck is it?
Wait, did I not...
Whoops.
I might...
Wait, where is it?
Did I not install it?
Wait, I thought I bought...
Oh my god, I didn't even finish buying the game.
What?
I'm like...
I was like...
I had it in my car and I didn't even fucking...
I didn't even fucking buy it yet.
Alright, God's like, where is it?
Where did the game go?
Alright, there we go.
There you go.
Bum bum bum.
Bum bum.
All right.
Let me know if the audio is okay, sound team.
There you go.
We're collecting anonymous gameplay data.
That's right.
Collect my data.
Let's do it.
I mean, it's easier than buying it off of Google or the
black market.
websites.
I'm making it easier for them, you know?
If they really wanted my data.
All right.
Welcome to Scritchy Scratchy.
In this game, you scratch a lot.
If you're prone to risk playing, classic.
All right.
My day job.
Oh, I wrote back to my nine to five.
I go, I stream
10 to work in a real job.
$2.
I'll do another one.
Wait, that gives me like a $1 lottery.
Like, scratch a win.
Gold Rush!
Let's go!
Alright.
Yeah, I got a trash can.
I feel like I need a trash can.
Wait, where do I...
How do I buy a ticket?
Alright.
Swish, swish, swish.
Swish, swish.
Wash!
Fasting!
Alright, nice.
Swish, swish, swish, swish.
Alright.
Gotta work hard to gamble my life away.
I'm all in.
Wait, is that not clean?
I know, two dollars, please?
Where the fuck is my lottery ticket?
This was the whole point.
I...
No!
No, don't let my boss know!
I'm so sorry!
You can't win every time.
Sometimes you get a negative payup.
Oh my god, there was already a gamba.
But don't worry, you can just throw it in the trash.
Okay, he'll never know.
He didn't know.
Guys.
Need a loan, huh?
No worries.
Let me send you the contract.
No need to read the fine print.
Just sign your name right at the bottom.
them all right wait a minute oh my god guys i'm gonna get
six thousand dollars let's fucking go
yeah great decision by the way our loans have a six thousand
percent interest rate That means I get it, right?
Don't keep it.
That can't be too bad.
When I hit the lottery, I can pay it all back in one go.
So make sure you pay out.
You'll get a random negative effect until the loan is played
off in full.
You can view your loan info in the top right corner.
Is that my loan?
300.
One in 20 tickets was different from what you ordered.
It's okay, guys.
But after I win the big number, they'll all go away.
They'll all go away, guys.
They're gonna regret this when I get my million dollars from
the lottery.
While this game teaches Doki how to avoid mode on
Earthplates.
Tired day job?
I got the perfect thing for you.
Scratch-off tickets.
Oh, my finally!
There we go.
The real game starts now.
Oh, wait.
That's not what... Oh, I need $10.
Okay.
Alright.
Swish, swish, swish.
Alright, nice.
Alright, money?
Money?
Oh, 25!
I told you!
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
I told you!
Oh!
Moon, Moon, oh my god, $10.
Let's go.
Never punish.
Moon, Moon, money.
Another $10.
Let's go.
Moon, Moon, $10.
Oh my god, I could keep playing this forever.
I took so while to scratch those, don't you worry.
I have just upgrading your scratch tools, make scratching a
breeze.
Trust me, you're going to need the extra power for this
tougher...
codings later on and you can you upgrade your luck amazing
oh scratch luck okay wait do i have enough scratch size i
don't need that okay moon moon money nice moon oh man okay
it's fine that's fine i've been winning too much you know
just been winning too much
more money moon moon cash oh my god they just want me to
scratch for the rest of my life and i'll take those oh my
god is that 32 32 dot never punished never punished see yeah
keep on digging keep on digging and then you can hit the
pile of diamonds oh we got a new ticket available for you
This one has way better prizes, but my unit needs some extra
luck to win them.
Okay, I don't have a lot of luck.
Holy shit, $100.
Do you think I make a made of money?
Not yet.
They're gonna regret this.
They're gonna regret this when I win that jackpot.
I don't need scratch size.
I'm investing.
This coin has been with me since day one.
I always remember the little people.
I got a good feeling about this one.
Me too.
Oh my god.
I told you.
Look at that.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I said I've had a good feeling and I was fucking right.
Okay, we're going to have to get $200 though here.
All right.
Money, money, money.
Oh, look at that.
It just keeps the money just keeps on rolling.
It never stops.
It keeps on rolling and it keeps on jackpot jackpot.
Oh my god, it's so easy.
Holy shit.
I am so good at this.
It's so easy.
I think I should have.
I accidentally should.
I was an accident.
I forgot to.
Oh, it was no accident.
It was no accident.
I didn't need no luck upgrade.
None of this is ever an accident.
Holy shit, I'm rolling.
It's just been win after win after win after win after win
after win.
There are never any accident here in the dokeyburg.
I'm so rich now.
I don't need to do my day job.
This is my day job.
I just scratch tickets.
Pay off your loan.
Oh, I should.
It does go higher, right?
All right.
Pay off.
Look at that.
And I just keep on going.
I just keep on scratching.
I keep on scratching.
I'm gonna wait until my luck pays off even more before we
buy the 100 tickets.
all those tickets yourself unlock scratch bot oh my god
we're we're enterprising now we're gonna be on the stock
market soon oh it's a thousand dollars we're gonna go public
the scratch and win company incorporated let's go oh yeah
now now it's 20 now oh wait this was easier
oh my god just keep on scratching we're going in the scratch
and wreck it alright now I maxed it out holy shit I found a
loony guys no more scratching with a fucking nickel or a
penny no more penny scratches I got the I got the loony in
here alright there we go
nice luck time don't worry I'll get back all that money look
at that look how lucky I am okay maybe not that one to win
to an over okay now look how lucky I am oh oh I told you I
told you when you scratch the apple tree look out for worms
is here a worm don't scratch worms only give they're fully
scratched why the fuck is that what what if i get a worm the
cops show was up and beats me up it takes my lottery ticket
what the fuck kind of system is that oh my god is that
another 500 let's go
yeah like he's got a worm get it
shows up outside my door.
And then it takes my computer.
I'll have 2,000.
I'm going to try and get the 5,000 luck first before I
invest in the before I invest in the fucking apple tree.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay, let's buy more.
Get that dopamine rush all at once.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I have a thousand dollar luck.
You can't do you know who I am?
There we go.
Yeah, that's right.
You know who I am All right Grab another one of this How is
this still level one after all this?
Oh My god Jackpot Jack fucking pot.
Okay, we just need We're gonna need like 2k 2k and then i
can get more luck more scratch luck oh my god the mini
scratches they hit hard i'm a millionaire now with my four
thousand dollars oh i forgot about the auto scratch i'm just
been i've been doing this like a peasant okay uh there we go
there we go like a peasant
do this.
All right.
There you go.
Ooh, 650.
That has to be a Dario.
That's my upgrade.
The D.
O.
stands for dollar bills, baby.
Exactly.
Oh, my God.
He's working so slow.
Okay.
1,000.
Let's give him a big boy.
Let's give him a big boy meal.
But.
Come on, mini scratch.
What the fuck you mean?
I paid big money to cheat.
To be skillful and lucky.
Checker.
Checker coin.
Someone checker coin.
All right.
Now we try to treat.
all right apple
minus 2 000 holy shit the bank calls me is like we found out
you found fucking got the worm i'm sorry i'm sorry but the
law says we gotta beat you up now
be okay that's get worm oh my god it's just flowers okay
there's the apple
and not get oh I could have I could have I just I could have
just I could have scratched more I didn't realize I thought
it was a one and done thing I really did I was like damn
really that's damn I can at least scratch one time.
Yeah, it should leave.
Goddamn B.
Okay, there we go.
There's the apple.
I can't believe it.
It's just apples and worms.
All right, this card fucking sucks, though.
Oh, my God.
Nope, JK.
JK, I just made it back.
Made my money back.
B.
Is that another apple?
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
Never fucking mind.
There we go.
Okay, can I grab?
Okay, we can grab a...
I'll grab the strength and the speed.
He needs to be a little faster.
Do I get some little pennies real quick?
Wait, what's the tin coin?
Oh, it's stronger.
Oh my god!
I need a diamond coin soon!
Holy shit, it's so much faster now.
Someone gave me a goddamn diamond coin.
Oh, these...
Alright, it's fine.
What the fuck?
Where are my winnings?
I'm not here to fuck around.
You think this is my first rodeo?
My first scratch and win?
I've been scratching since I was a kid.
I was molded.
oh my god so easy just thread in the just thread in the coin
oh and then the bonus just start threading the start
threading the the tickets don't know what it means oh my god
extra bonus oh oh yeah huh huh what do you mean what the
fuck do you mean are you oh my god i'm gonna i'm gonna find
where you live ticket are you serious okay fuck this throw
this card away it's junk
uh let me grab the apple tree i need 10k we ain't playing no
more one two one scratcher please you give me the winnings,
right?
Annie, yeah, yeah, of course.
Of course I will.
I know, scammer.
Annie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm sorry, Andy.
It was not a win.
I'm sorry.
Not everyone can be lucky like me.
Annie, I'm really sorry about that.
No money.
No money there.
Alright, what do I get?
Okay.
Oh, my 10,000?
I got my money.
back oh look at wait what oh i need three in the row are you
fucking oh my god this one's a lot harder i only got half of
my money back there that's so unlucky guys no price you know
just gotta keep on scratching one day you'll be just as good
one day
just gotta keep on scratching You'll get there soon, buddy.
You'll get there.
Okay, now these aren't getting me the money I want.
There has to be a...
Okay, worm, worm.
Okay, apple.
What are exciting new exciting product available?
A special device that will make it way easier to feed your
scratch bot.
A table fan!
Just click and hold to blow tickets right into the scratch
bot.
Oh my god, wait, that is actually pretty convenient.
I gotta grab a fad.
A $50,000...
Okay, what economy are we living in right now?
What...
What economy are we living in?
Where is...
Where is fucking...
50k for a goddamn...
For a goddamn fad.
A top quality fad.
please please oh oh no the quick cache it wasn't so quick
are you serious it's just all worms it's just all worms
it's just all worms okay apple be worm so i haven't got that
Okay, Apple, Apple, there we go, made back to, we made back
our money.
Oh, wait, what am I doing?
Scratching it myself like a fucking peasant.
Ten months from now is economy.
I was going to say, are we in Zimbabwe right now?
What the fuck?
Okay, Red Apple.
Red Apple.
All right, double the money now.
All right, nice.
the money.
Okay, red apple, red apple.
Oh, three apples?
Four!
Red flesh, bluefish.
All right.
All right, put that in there.
There we go.
All right, more apple trees.
Got that quick.
This one is a scam.
Quick cash is not as quick as I thought it'd be.
Like, look, I just got back 10k, which is like I fucking
spent on this goddamn ticket the shit is a scab but not this
one though all right nice got our money's worth enables Joki
scratch addiction well thank you mr.
Pritchard thank you thank you you miss three app green
apples at this point rip three grand no no it was a leaf yes
it was see that's a leaf it was a leaf guys i would never
miss a green apple thank you the super chat bowser bowser
thank you for thank you thank you
oh my god i've been scratching for so long i didn't even
realize i can afford i forgot about the i don't need a fan i
i have my hands for that
yeah money money oh my god please Give me a dollar bill,
please.
I invested in luck.
I went to the fortune teller.
Oh, okay.
At least I made half my money back.
I went to the fortune teller today and she said, and I paid
her a hundred grand, and she said my luck will now improve.
That's what she said.
I think I actually tricked myself into playing a clicker
game, but instead of clicking and scratching, I, I thought
there would be more roguelites in here.
I thought, oh my god.
Oh, and it was worth it.
Oh my, the payout.
This fan is great and all, but something might want to save
tickets for later.
That's what the sticky mat is for.
Wait, what?
Oh, if I, like, fuck up the fan or some shit.
All right, let's grab the speed, and the strength.
Okay.
Green apple and green apple.
There you go.
All right, let's grab.
I'll grab more for this guy.
Oh, my God.
I might actually start needing the fan.
He's scratching more than I can put it in.
And we may have a nice trash size.
Not paying for baby.
no more this is real shit now all right green apple tree
cold apple green apple oh my god and is that another green
apple come here baby okay all right nice that's fine um it's
not idle clicker uh it's idol a scratcher
no the difference guys holy shit I'm fucking raking it in
okay so how does this work how does the fan work like I need
to figure this out okay
okay what the fuck is the point I paid 50 grand for this fan
to manually click clicking it there's no way there's there's
no way i have to manually click my fan do you know who i am
um i think i got scammed guys okay maybe i do this and then
when i scratch this nope nope just stays there never mind i
thought if i All right, never mind.
I don't understand.
How does this fucking thing work?
Oh, buy a lot and then press it?
Okay.
That's still stupid as hell.
All right.
This quick cache is not...
Oh, never mind.
It's quite quick.
Okay.
All right, I'll trust in it.
All right.
I trust the system.
There we go.
Uh, quick cash.
I don't know why I bought the sticky mad.
Just was like, and I have so much disposable income.
I see you, and I was like, bye.
I had no idea why I did it.
I don't know what it does.
I didn't really read it.
I should actually start reading it.
I'll blow it over.
there you go all right what does it do well i just own it
that's that's what it does i just own it oh nice 32 000
let's go oh my god i got lucky cat i need 300 grand i think
i can afford it
i have no time to read i only have time to scratch It's all
about the scratches, guys.
Yeah.
There we go.
All right.
Quick cash.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
It is quick.
Look at that.
Quickest cash of my life.
10,065 grand.
Bam.
Bam, baby.
Okay, got half my money back.
That's all right.
Don't forget the scratch bot speed.
Don't buy more tickets.
Just keep buying.
Spend, spend, spend.
You gotta spend money to make money.
You know the drill, guys.
Like, put cash, too.
Oh, my God.
I need more.
I need 200 grand.
I need more strength.
Don't make it.
He didn't use the cheap shit for these scratch cards, guys.
Okay, 32.
Nice.
Money, money, money.
Must be funny.
In a rich man's world.
But not money, money, money.
It must be funny.
In a rich man's world.
There we go.
Yeah, that shit is coded.
He's crashed.
These scratcher wins are coated with, like, gold right now.
That's how hard it is to scratch the winnings.
So I need an aluminum coin.
Soon I'm going to need diamond, because only diamond can
scratch diamond.
Okay.
Put more here.
Oh, shit.
Luck is available.
Fuck.
I'm going to grab the aluminum coin.
I need the extra scratch.
Okay.
I need the extra.
It's okay.
I can make it back.
I can make it back so easy.
I can get that Scratch luck up so easy.
It's Amateur Hour.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Scratch, scratch, scratch.
Scratch, scratch.
I like how they introduced roguelike elements.
In the very beginning and then never again.
And then...
It's just, you're like, oh, you paid off your loan.
All right, that's, that's the roguelike.
Back to scratching.
Now go back to it.
All right, nice.
There we go.
Now my luck is back.
Can I get the, okay, 625, 250 scratch bots?
strength.
Okay, I do want to try the lucky cat, but I need to, like,
make enough money for that.
That's fine.
Alright, nice.
Just, I got the 84 grand.
I keep forgetting I already bought tickets.
It's just instinct to scrap.
Just buy another one.
Yeah.
All right.
Nice.
Don't you want to upgrade?
I'm not going back.
All right.
Don't you want to upgrade your day job?
I'm not going back, baby.
This is my day job now.
This is it.
Now here's a merch idea.
Myers picked for scratch coin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ages.
All right.
Oh, you're right.
I can't.
Oh, yeah, I just realized I now have enough money to buy the
to use this instead of the mini scratchers.
All right, let's do one lucky cat, please.
Okay, okay.
Well, I just realized that there is a minus 500k there.
All right, 100.
That's the pop.
bad 200k oh my god okay i mean me in the back okay there you
go i realize i can now i was like oh what do you mean quick
cash i don't have enough money to use quick cash guys i
forgot wait i do i do have enough money for quick cash oh my
god i forgot i'm in a higher tax bracket now i'm I don't
need a scroll.
I don't...
Oh, my God.
I just upgraded my...
Oh, I figured...
Oh, never mind.
I realized the diamond was...
The diamond was not for me.
My bad.
I got really excited because I was like, Oh, my God, guys.
I got the diamond.
But I forgot to need...
Oh!
look at that never doubted for a second never fucking
doubted okay 100k fish oh my god really come on okay we
gotta what's this okay 300k we made back our okay we made
back our money okay dead fish dead fish dead fish all right
we just made back our money that's fine i don't know these
these ones suck honestly the only time it's good is if we
get the five million payout because their tickets already
cost like three grand all right there we go we made back our
money and got another hundred grand oh look at that look at
that got everything we need and i can buy more And then blow
that all the way down there.
Something green in the Bible.
Look at that.
I told you that loan was not a bad idea.
Are you fucking all duds?
How is this lucky?
Um, does he know who I am?
I am a level 6 scratch luck master.
Okay.
Nice.
I'll grab the 100k 100k is 100k at least holy I'm not I'm
not buying lucky cat it's just not worth it it's actually
it's not worth it I'm just gonna grab the quick cash yeah
these rates are fucked that that is a fucked up break they
have okay get the strength get another span speed and then
more quick cash oh look at that I'm just gonna grind for it
to luck.
I think I need to be luckier for Lucky Cat.
I don't think Lucky Cat's for me.
There we go.
We got some more Scratch.
Like, alright, now.
Alright, now.
Let's try Lucky Cat.
That's right.
I'm a different...
Oh.
Okay.
I'm a level 7!
Are you...
Okay.
I'll take...
I'll take the one paw print.
I'll mine this 100.
I'm a level 7 scratch luck.
Oh my god.
At least I made my money back.
I'll take it.
And we're all at night to get some.
We're all at night to bump up.
We're up at night to get lucky.
Okay, we're at more capacity.
And then...
that fan in okay maybe my luck changes here are you serious
okay we're not we're not scratching any more of that we're
doing more quick caches fuck this like look at that so easy
just rolls in all right now okay lucky cat there we go oh my
god oh my god i had to be a level 8 scratch luck.
All right, that, okay, there you go.
Now, now we're talking, guys.
Now we're talking.
All right.
Take that.
There we go.
Final chance.
Oh.
I don't know if I like that.
Final chance.
Seems a little Oh, that sounds fun.
It's like, you don't win anything.
You just die.
They come and get you.
Yeah.
That.
Bum, bum, bum.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm just glad I make my money back.
Need for show me how to earn money.
I'm going to go buy some scratch cards now.
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's just that easy, yes.
Oh, that's what the sticky mat does.
Oh, that makes more sense now.
Okay, so I just do that.
Like, I put the ones I want to scratch here.
Where does that give me 260?
Okay, nice.
I'm almost there for the...
Okay, I'm there now.
all right final chance guys
okay oh I actually die I
oh so that's what they mean by final chance that you know
that that makes a lot more sense you know that for sure
Rihanna needs more.
Does she just...
What?
Wait.
I lost everything.
I...
I lost...
I lost everything.
Damn it.
I...
Okay, we gotta grab that.
do I do prestige like how do I play oh wait the fuck is
bigger sponge okay we definitely gotta get that and then I
don't know what big sponge is but oh it's my day job
what the fuck is respect and prestige like what am I
supposed to do of this did i do it all right don't keep
playing russian like he's pulling the trigger in her run god
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you no you know
what guys what i had everything i swear i had it all oh now
i have it okay guys i was a million there guys before i was
i worked here i used to be a millionaire i'm sure you were
doki sure i had it all all the tickets in the world i was
able to afford a fan i i used to the deal thank you for the
five gift and chips thank you thank you up oh wait oh my god
my tiny little penny tiny tiny look at the size of that
penny my coin my coin was made of aluminum guys aluminum I
used to rule the world.
Unlocked upgrades.
Now I have this fake penny coin that you can find at a kid's
cashier toy.
Oh my god.
10.
$10.
I used to buy I used to buy those 300 grand tickets.
We were not the same.
So sure you were grandpa.
Oh yeah, take you back to bed.
You I don't understand.
My robot could scratch 20 tickets at once.
I mean, this may have been since you lost her, but can I
borrow some money?
Simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ma'am, this is a Wendy's.
Oh my god, the mini scratch.
I didn't buy any luck, but like, don't worry, I don't need
no luck.
Okay, alright, wait, I earned my ticket back?
I got my ticket back, though.
My little teeny-weeny dollars.
Oh my god, only $21 per win.
How the mighty have fallen.
I have to manually put my ticket on the buy.
okay that's 500 not yet oh my god it's i forgot it's three
you need three okay okay that's 200 that's 137 i'll take
those i take those i'll take whatever thing i can grab
okay all right nice That's three to win.
Why am I still spending money on that?
I have to use my hands to put it in the machine.
I don't know how to live like this no more.
You can never go back.
You can never go back after you have the good life.
After you tasted a fine china.
Okay, almost at a thousand.
Can we?
We need to get a thousand to get our scratch luck up.
Like a cave, man.
Where is Wilson to scratch this for me?
Where's my butler?
Did he survive?
Did he make it to the other world?
okay now i should have enough luck for the mini scratch
cards god fucking i'm not a trash cat god fucking god damn
it okay there are 186 i'll take those i i bet my brother
better also get killed too it's like uh it's like the the
pharaoh thing where when a pharaoh dies like all his
servants and his pets also go with him it doesn't matter
yeah that's right my brother must also be east and guide i'm
going he's coming down here with me okay now i should be
lucky enough right you can't be doing rest of my life okay
there we go there we go 500 500 it's not the same after
winning millions and millions of dollars it's not the same
it's not get the same rush as i did just won this off a 20
scratcher thanks for showing me the light media thank you
for the super chat
I can't do the apple tree, man.
I don't have enough luck for this.
Alright, two.
$500.
That's fine.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm running less than I did before.
I feel like everything feels so slow.
I had a system.
I automated it perfectly.
Okay, I got the spot.
Oh my god.
Please, where's my 50k fan?
Now I know why the fans were so expensive.
It was worth it.
Good.
That's good.
650, 850.
Okay, now let's try.
Let's try our luck with the tree.
Oh, oh, oh.
That was two, that was my life savings.
Oh, that's awkward.
That was my life savings right there.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
I worked so hard for that.
okay 2000 in the trade quick cash I don't even I don't even
have the money for quick cash
okay I just need one more are you serious not even one oh my
god please I need more luck oh right at least two win is
winning Are you fucking kidding me?
That's all three in a row.
What happened?
What?
My luck also stayed in my old life?
okay, we'll grab the tin coin.
But I really need the luck, though.
Not for the fan.
Yes, I can't fucking afford the fan.
I don't remember when it comes out.
Yeah.
At least a thousand.
Okay, a thousand there.
We're almost close to 5k.
There we go.
Now I should be able to do the lucky one.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
I don't understand.
I paid to win.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, now.
Now I should be able to do this.
Okay, apple, apple, be...
God, fucking, okay.
Oh, apple?
Alright, that's fine, that's fine.
We got our money's worth.
Okay, apple.
That's a leaf.
Yeah, that's a leaf.
It's okay, we got our money back again.
Let's put more scratches in here.
Worm, apple.
Okay.
Apple.
We're slowly making back our money.
All right.
A double apple.
What's this?
Okay, that's a B.
All right, it's fine.
All right.
I don't think we have the luck yet.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, I almost owe the IRS.
I...
I didn't know my own strength, guys.
I just upgraded it.
I just went to the gym.
Oh my god, there we go.
That's the money I'm talking about.
I...
The IRS was just at my door.
They were ready.
They heard there was a worm incoming.
It was a code worm.
Oh, there we go.
My 50 grand fucking fan is here.
okay
that's apple apple oh my god another apple there we go okay
30k i'm gonna grab the scratch luck and then aim for the fan
here now okay all right it's work it's fan time this is it
the investment of my lifetime.
Yeah, Apple.
Worm.
I should actually...
No, the fan is more important, I feel like.
Actually, five grand?
That's fine.
Five grand works.
He came to me with money in his hand.
He offered me.
I didn't even ask him.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Oh, I did not know!
No!
It didn't mean to scratch by that one.
It was reflex from my past life.
But I had everything.
Oh, goodbye, 10 grand.
Goodbye.
But I had everything.
Oh.
okay we're almost there
we're almost there apple tree don't fail me now okay 6,500
10k just like that okay nice okay that's good that's good
we're almost there we're almost there to the 50 grand Oh my
god, we are here now.
We're here.
Oh my god.
Get in here.
There we go.
I don't have to be a fucking peasant no more.
Okay, worm.
Apple, apple, apple.
I need more luck if I want to do the quick cash.
oh my god okay just like fuck this i'll work for you no more
climb down of poverty again and i'll keep on doing it that's
right i can blow this over there no more dishes for this
bird i'm in a different tax bracket And I'll do it again and
again and again.
Okay.
You should be washing my dishes.
I'll grab it.
Okay.
All right.
Uh, apple tree.
Okay, double.
Double red.
That's always good.
Oh my god.
I can like...
Look how efficient I am.
Nice.
I'm so efficient now.
I can...
Nice.
Cold.
See, y'all know I'm like, nah, get out of here.
Apple.
I just need one click on each.
And I know now.
I recognize the apples.
Oh, I got scratch size.
That's good.
We need that.
But we need more luck.
We need more luck.
Give me that luck.
Yeah, apple.
Apple, double apple.
Apple, worm, apple, worm.
What's this?
Okay, flower.
Yeah, apple, apple, apple.
Oh my god, is that triple apples?
Yeah, at least we got one apple though.
An apple's an apple.
Oh shit, I forgot about the fan.
I got two invested in the apples.
Gold apple.
Oh.
The efficiency.
I got a system in place now.
Oh my god, like, I know exactly where they are now too.
Yeah, one green apple.
Look at that.
I even know where it's placed.
I know my placements.
Do we have enough luck?
We might be able to grab quick cash now.
God.
Oh, okay, we made it back.
We made our money back.
That's fine.
Okay, we didn't make it all back, but...
Okay, we'll try again Maybe I was wrong Are you fucking
kidding me?
I two in a row I two in a row of everything else Are you
can't be fucking serious Okay, there is Okay, okay, okay We
made back, okay, we made back Everything we lost Alright,
you know, I'll take this We made back everything we lost
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine Yeah
Okay, this is bullies I'm going back to apples.
I'm going back to apples.
This is bullshit.
Apples never failed me.
Oh my god.
I told you.
Apples know what I want.
Holy shit.
It's raining apples.
It really is.
Okay, get that fan in.
Okay, grab the scratch bot speed.
Oh, I forgot I was saving for it.
I forgot what I was saving for.
We needed a luck.
Oopsie.
I mean, we can...
We keep on grinding it.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
It's a bit slower than I expected, though.
There we go.
Oh, my 625?
Okay, this might be hard.
Okay.
That's an apple.
A golden apple.
Apple, apple, apple, apple.
And that's a worm.
Watch.
Oh, wait.
That's a flower.
A bee.
Blow that fan in.
Maybe I'll test my luck one more time.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
You know what?
I believe now.
I believe.
Come on, baby.
Y'all in.
Truly it's quick cash.
I knew I knew I just needed to believe.
I knew I just needed to believe.
on believing okay keep on believing what happened to it wait
guys guys uh-huh guys
oh wait a minute
okay let's keep that money rolling in it's okay this has to
be god fucking It's fine.
It's fine.
The moment I get the big ticket number, there we go.
There we go.
That's what I'm saying.
The moment I get that big ticket number.
And that would be a three cash.
All right, there you go.
It's big cash time.
It actually is big cash time.
right scratch those big cash scratch it oh yes yes all right
Apple do this well oh they scratched the big cash for me and
then can I upgrade anything not I don't need it.
I scratch big cash while my little boy scratches big cash
too.
We're living the high life.
All in on big cash.
All in to the moon.
The big cash moon.
Yes.
Okay.
Coin coin coin.
It's fine.
Look at that.
130k.
Easy.
Here comes the big money now.
Big ticket scratch.
We will.
I think I'll save for the scratch bot speed.
Right now.
We need more luck for sure.
Let's grab this.
okay big money small money
it's fine it's fine a couple of duds no worries no worries i
make it all back anyway easy
make it all back you didn't get okay last time i did lucky
cat i need like level eight we need level eight lucky cat we
want to be lucky guys i've learned Learn the lucky cat ways.
Oh my God.
Fucking easy.
Look at that.
There we go.
We're almost there.
We're almost at the tax bracket for lucky cat.
Oh.
All right.
Speed.
Strength.
Scratch size.
Oh my god.
God is watching me.
He's like, you don't have enough money.
You have some more.
I was like, thanks, God.
We live in the good life now.
need more and i was like you are so right we got some
exclusive they are only available to our most loyal
customers they're a lot tougher than what you're used to you
get stuck you can always prestige or spend it all right what
is it sand dollars what the fuck the fuck is sand dollars
over there I mean I should be able I should be able to do
lucky cat now yeah there you go oh dude now now I can do
lucky cat 600 oh my god oh a million in one go that's
what I'm talking about
I don't put them all here
All right.
I feel like I should upgrade the fan, right?
Nah.
Fuck it.
I'll do it.
Just for fun.
Yeah, the fan upgrade was not worth it.
Never mind.
No longer.
I no longer do it for fun.
This is business now.
We're all business.
Oh, look at that.
We're worried.
We're worried if we're business cat.
Okay, Paul.
Oh, another jackpot.
Another fucking jackpot.
Oh!
And is that another jackpot?
And get marvel at all that you've achieved and get a look at
what's still available to achieve.
There's so many even rewards to collect.
Get another jackpot.
Is that another jackpot for me?
Oh, you shouldn't have.
Oh my god, that was a 0.1%, I think.
I don't think that was a fish.
I don't think that...
Oh my god, no, it was a fish.
It was a fish, Doki.
It was...
Oh, let's go.
Alright, we have sand dollars.
I don't know what it is.
One million in the sand.
Match three to win.
Oh, okay.
Oh, is that easy?
I
haven't seen a single dead fish in a while all right nice oh
no get over here oh oh get over here you're not supposed to
be there oh my god I've actually hit copper coin now magenta
super thank you thank you lucky cat reminds me that there's
a bbc sherlock episode where an asian woman convinces
sherlock to buy a lucky statue statue because his wife would
like it like it next time we see it it's sitting by watson
what did they mean by this they're very good friends oh see
thank you for the magenta super thank you thank you they are
really really good friends what else what they mean by it
don't fuck it i'll get grab it fuck it oh die twice die
three times i have a mundo create an artificial soul that
did not okay i would i was like what the fuck is this it's
like but it's like an egg timer i was like that is no egg
that is that's no fucking egg okay don't
worry i'll put it here
five more quick cash real quick i do think wait can i
collect the rewards oh i wasn't oh there it is all right
I don't think I'm lucky enough for Scritchy Scratchy catalog
too I'll try one more time Oh wait I am Let's go Wait I
Never mind Never mind I am lucky enough Let's go Oh I am I
realized I am not I just got I only got $8 million Never
mind We're back to Lucky Cat JK I only got $8 million and
they cost me 20 million.
The map does not add up for some reason.
I might have been losing money there.
What if I can?
Oh, I can spend.
No, I can't spend it.
Not until I get Isakad again.
Oh, fuck.
I was supposed to...
God damn, I was supposed to spend it on luck.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
650.05% chance.
I was going to say, I might as well put this in the
scratcher, but then it said minus 650.
And I don't know if I want to risk that for the 0.5%.
That's the gamma that I'm a little bit afraid to take.
They can go fast.
All right.
I believe you.
Alright.
Yeah, if I'm going to get the dead fish, I'll get it on my
own terms.
Oh, and I'll scratch this one for fun.
Oh.
It's fine.
I'll grab the other stuff.
Alright.
Go in there.
Blow into speed bot.
He's hungry.
He's so hungry.
Alright.
I love that.
Bum bum bum bum bum.
Makes me want to scratch more.
Bum bum bum bum.
Just makes me Oh, it just makes me want to keep on
scratching.
Feed me.
Feed him!
He's so hungry.
to keep eating he wants to consume okay now let's try
another sand dollar this should be it are you fucking okay
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's all right it's all right maybe i just need to
be level 10.
Maybe I just need to be level 10, guys.
Maybe, maybe it's just a level 10 thing.
Oh my god, it's gonna take 1.95 billion.
Never mind, let's just, let's just rip it.
I don't have enough money for that.
Oh, come on.
Okay, there we go.
25 million there i'm made back 32 i mean that's fine that's
that's all right that's okay that's that's okay that in here
grab the copper coin uh you know all in all in it's just
lucky cats now You go scratch.
Or you get your lucky cat.
Okay.
Maybe, like, if I keep scratching the sand dollars, there is
a chance that I can hit the big money.
If I just keep on scratching, then I'll make back all the
money I lost.
And I'll make it all back.
See, look at that.
I already made back a ticket that I lost last time.
scratching let's keep on scratching I'll make it all my
money back that's how percentages work guys
all right keep on scratching keep on scratching scratch
scratch scratch scratch scratch scratch scratch oh scratch
scratch scratch
it's simple it's simple math That's how ratios work.
Okay, I need 1.95.
Okay, we're almost there.
And the next one will be a winner.
I won something.
There we go.
I need to feed my little dog here.
Not dad, but my new dog.
my my virtual dog he's hungry right now dad outside it's
like I'm hungry all right this that should be enough no it's
not it is not enough yeah okay hundred eight we just need 80
more 800 000 more easy just 800 000 more need somehow
collecting all your scratchbot winnings mundo can help with
that and she's cute too oh mundo wait actually i do need
mundo's help oh billion all right mundo don't know how All
right, Mundo.
Two billion dollars to collect my money.
I feel like I can outsource this to someone else.
Just, I don't know.
That's how I feel about it.
This feels like something I can outsource.
Okay, oh, not yet.
552, that should be enough.
Nope.
Apparently it's 1.95.1 or some shit.
There we go.
Now I should be lucky enough again.
Yeah, I should be lucky for this.
There we go.
Now this is worth my time.
Let's go.
My little boy!
He has very expensive taste now.
There we go, jackpot.
He's an expensive boy!
Only the best for him!
It's fine, I don't care that we lost money there.
We didn't make back so much more from it.
All right, we're almost at 2 million for Mundo.
We're gonna get a little friend.
A little cat friend for my little dog.
Yeah.
What the fuck is Lucky Cat still in that pile?
All right, there we go.
All right, Mundo, do your thing.
Oh, shit, wait, he is doing it.
Oh my god, go Mundo, go.
Oh my god, he's doing it Go Mundo Do that thing
Alright, let's just keep on scratching it There you go
Okay, we need Alright, scratch my back Alright We need Oh
shit, no jellyfish Okay, I was Not paying attention about
that part.
Okay.
Jellyfish.
Alright, there you go.
575.
Oh, okay.
We made it back.
We made back our money.
Do I need to buy a fan?
I should buy fan speed.
No.
Because of Mundo.
Oh, snake size.
Alright.
Turtle tab.
Now to be aware of jellyfish.
There you go.
I knew this was worth it.
Oh yeah, crab.
Wait.
Alright, nice.
We got fish here.
Okay, jellyfish crab.
Oh, we got the fish though.
Eh, half is good.
We're not doing snake eyes yet.
We gotta be level 12 before we are eligible.
It's like be a level 12 dungeon master.
We ain't gonna go straight in.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck am I doing?
This is Mundo's job.
I'm not here for that type of labor anymore.
I'm better than this.
I'm...
I know my worth.
What happened to you, Doki?
I...
What happened to you?
What happened to the little people?
It's gone to her head.
It's all about the scratches, boy.
It's all scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch.
Alright, Mondo.
Do your thing.
Let's see.
I need to have 9.7.
And they're all scratchable.
I do need more luck for the turtle, though, I feel.
I feel like the turtle is not making as much money right now
in the turtle.
Because if I don't...
Yeah.
If I don't get, like, the 650 million, it's just not worth
it.
Oh, nice.
I got 65, though.
I haven't seen the crabs for a while.
He's doing his best.
Yeah.
Scratch, scratch, scratch, scratch.
Oh my god, I'm just scratching for an hour.
Oh shit, no, wait, I don't need lucky cat.
That's peasant money.
I get in here.
Back in there, Mundo.
All right, now we try snake as when we can afford it.
God, it be in the middle is actually...
annoying what's
this okay goldfish oh oh that was close that was close i had
like a huge belief that there was no jellyfish in the middle
oh my god the double jellyfish i upgraded my luck
yeah there you go the billion wait it was jackpot
I didn't know I threw it in the trash The cashier is gonna
take the money now I didn't know It looked like a regular
jellyfish No, take it back No Wait, oh my god, never
punished, let's go Yay!
Never punish.
Let's fucking go.
Let's...
I just made the janitor a billion dollars.
Let's go.
And I didn't learn my lesson.
.
I didn't learn my lesson.
Let's fucking go.
I learned nothing.
Alright, snake eyes.
Match the amount of eyes with dice of the kind, but avoid
the ones.
Okay.
Okay, that's the one.
Three, three, two, one.
Okay, that's a one.
All right.
I think that has to be a one.
Yeah, so.
Unless, unless, whoa.
All right, that's done.
Yeah, I'm losing 2 billion.
It has to be!
There has to be two ones right here!
Yeah, I was trashing it.
That shit was bullshit.
So I gotta buy more of this.
It would definitely be more luck.
Uh, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna work on luck first.
That?
Okay, that's jackpot.
Okay.
Ah!
The turtle is so hard.
It's so hard.
This jackpot is also a jellyfish.
They're called jellyfishes.
It canceled out the jackpot.
Yeah.
How is it?
It's 8% and I got two of you?
Yeah.
No, you don't have eyes.
Okay, I should have luck.
Better luck now.
Okay, there you go.
No eyes.
Alright.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay, now I should be able to do snake eyes.
Okay.
Grab.
Scratch side.
Okay, two.
all right that's a one all right three
okay that's a one yeah yeah yeah just I'm just trying to be
safe I'm just trying to be safe
yeah we need What can we upgrade?
Whoops.
Alright, fuck it.
Send a little apple tree in there too.
Jackpot.
Okay, all winners.
I need more luck, but I don't know how we're going to get
there.
Okay.
Oh, nice jackpot.
Guys, for this one.
have to be so careful
snake eyes one is hell too I think I actually have to for
the snake eyes I definitely have to like wait until my luck
is better oh I gotta speed up Mundo I should actually how
much is Mundo alright Mundo do your thing get me that money
yeah yeah all right i'm getting a lot of frequent jackpots
maybe you're right maybe i don't have to worry
where the fuck did he come from where did he come from okay
there's there's the bad there's the evil jellyfish i see you
i see your little evil eyes
At least it's faster now.
Unlock the bomb.
Like, do I die?
Like, am I...
Am I fucking just perished?
What do you mean, the bomb?
You cut the wrong wire.
Your entire office explodes.
Oh my god, I got the bronze coin, finally.
The double jellyfishers?
No way.
Okay, he's not friendly looking.
He doesn't have eyes.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Poor billion.
If I fuck up.
Alright, let's go.
I think I need more luck.
If I'm doing the...
Give me more sand dollars.
I definitely need more luck.
I can't...
The snake eyes are is too...
It's like...
It's not worth scratching until I get that luck up.
Until I'm level 14 luck.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh!
Magic.
Magic number.
Okay.
Ah!
I never win those.
Oh my god, there's another one.
Another magic number.
Okay.
Come on!
The double duds, too?
Just take me out back.
What's the point?
Alright, there you go.
Okay.
Oh, scratch, scratch, scratch.
You have eyes?
You have...
Alright, they all match.
We're almost there for the 244.
Go, Mundo!
Go!
This is your purpose, Mundo!
Keep on collecting my money!
Okay.
God!
I got a little cocky.
It's like, truly, the fact that it was too jellyfish.
Yeah.
Grab that in here.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
We made it.
Oh.
I'm gonna see this.
God, God, fucking...
It's fine.
Yeah.
Okay, he has eyes.
It's fine.
Alright, we should be able to do snake eyes now.
Alright.
Four.
Oh, six.
okay oh another four that wouldn't be funny if we have four
fours oh it will be so funny god it's all right maybe this
one will work three six five six how am i getting six 20
percent percent chance is gonna happen all right all right
buddy uh okay no more snake eyes for me apparently all right
we gotta feed us gotta feed our two pets mundo and my little
bot okay one more one more time and maybe the other one
would be four fours nope it decided to try to give me oh
maybe this won't be oh oh where the where did the three come
from That's fine.
That's fine.
We're back to turtle.
It's turtle time again.
We just...
We live and die by turtle.
Oh my god.
I need to stop doing that.
I made zero dollars on that one.
No eyes.
And a jackpot here.
Oops.
All turtle.
Just all turtle.
fucking scratch it.
Just scratch it.
I don't care.
Just tell me how it's gonna just tell me how.
Oh, oh, and then suddenly I, oh, wow, wow.
Alright, cool.
Just prestige it.
How do I even prestige?
Oh, wait.
There it is.
Wait, does this mean I just die?
What happens if I prestige?
Do I just die?
Do I
wait, but I want to note the bomb.
Guys, what about the bomb?
Alright, we'll proceed.
I gotta make it to the end.
But the bomb.
No.
I need to know.
We're so close.
We're so close to the bomb.
Take the cash from Mundo.
Mundo's already Mundo's doing... Look at him.
He's passively doing it.
Wake up, Mundo.
Wake up.
Mundo.
He's doing it passively for me.
Oh, wait.
Do I have more badges?
Oh, shit, I do.
Nice.
Good job, Mundo.
All right, Mundo.
Go faster.
Oh shit, I accidentally spent it.
I don't want to spend my...
Oh, is this for a proceed?
I don't want to spend my tickets.
Is that my jackpot tickets?
Oh, here.
It's at the night market.
Ah, Mundo, do your thing, Mundo.
Oh hey, Mundo found a...
found this.
Oh my god.
God, the super jackpot.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go, Mundo.
That's my boy.
Oh my god.
I can't afford the bomb.
Alright.
Okay.
That's gray.
Oh, that's yellow.
Oh.
Oh, I'm gonna match two.
Wait, is this the bad yet?
Okay, that's the bad yellow.
Okay, that is also the bad side.
The bad red.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Wait, there's one more.
Oh, my God.
It's the bomb.
It's the fucking bomb.
Two trillion?
I don't even have two trillion.
trillion what do you mean dude trillion like this i'm
sending these to the cat i'm gonna let the cat do this all
right cat i believe you so much you won't lose me money in
this
minus 6.96 my 11 billion you know what it's worth it it's
worth just giving this to the cat What I lose is less than
what I gain.
Guys, I have to play the last chance.
There you go.
Alright, snake eyes.
One more chance.
One more time.
One last for the ride.
Four.
Six.
Okay, three, three, three, there we go.
I lost money.
There, there we go.
There we go.
All right, we're not doing that one again.
Please help Mundo.
Mundo, go do your thing, Mundo.
This is your new life now.
You just, I don't even need a scratch anymore.
Just go.
Go Mundo, go.
You know what?
I'll help you.
I'll help do it.
I'll help a little bit.
There you go.
Holy shit, Mundo.
Okay, maybe I should have...
Oh my god, Mundo.
How much money do we have in there?
Mundo.
What do you mean?
Oh my god, the super jackpot I'm sitting on billions
It keeps going it's still hopefully shit.
Okay, maybe I should have okay, maybe okay, maybe I should
have Claimed this a lot earlier I thought but don't what I
okay in my defense I thought Mundo was doing okay.
There we go.
Look at that.
Mundo's caught up.
He's caught up now, guys.
He's caught up.
I thought he was doing okay.
I didn't realize he was struck.
Mundo was... Mundo needed help.
Mundo was like, please.
I'm so... I'm so full.
Mundo needs rest.
Please let Mundo sleep.
I was like, here's some more food, Mundo.
Is Mundo hungry?
And Mundo, not hungry.
Mundo, want to sleep.
God, the snake eyes is just fucking bullshit.
Play the baby tickets.
Oh, yeah, I forgot about the baby.
baby tickets but I don't play them yeah I'll do the 10 ones
surely the jackpots in one of them and there are many
scratchers and then the apple trees and then the quick cash
and then the lucky cat and then I think I already have the
sand dollar one right Armando it's time to eat
there you go and then you know what let's have the thrill of
this it's been a while the same yeah we have to get the blue
star for the jackpot it's not the same guys just hasn't hit
the same okay wait mando i'll help mando out a little bit
all right mando speed there you go mando
There you go, Mundo.
You're doing great, Mundo.
Alright.
I need that final chance again.
I need the final chance.
I'm ready.
Alright, Snake Eyes.
We'll try again.
Or...
Behind?
How the fuck...
Okay, that is so bullshit.
This one is actually so bullshit.
It's like, this one's a real scam.
Like, how am I supposed to find five fives?
I'll try again.
This is a real scam.
Anyway, can I have, like, five more tickets, sir?
So I can, like, test out my theory real quick.
I need to test them out with my hypothesis.
to make to see if it is a scam or not oh my god i'd still
lose money i still i still lose money when when do i make
money like all right gold apple oh two worms
i'm supposed to find five fives
oh oh i made five oh i was look at the bomb Never mind.
Never mind.
Made money, guys.
Sorry, I was looking at the bomb.
Okay, that has to be five fives.
Okay.
Yes!
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, now it's worth it.
Okay, a 0.1 chance it's a 1.
Okay, now this is worth it.
All fives.
Let's see, yo.
Never mind, it's no longer a scam.
guys minus 17 billion dollar okay it's fine it's like little
jump change guys it's no longer a scam guys i
take everything back all in on snake eyes oh
my god this fucking game is a scam never mind i take that
back as well this snake eyes is a goddamn scam
Never mind, I take that back.
I take that back.
It's a good...
This is a good scrap card.
This is a good one.
Never mind, guys.
I take that, that back.
Oh, my God.
It's always jellyfish.
Oh, we're so back.
Oh, I bought the wrong one.
It's fine.
Yeah, I need more luck, though.
Put more on scratch.
Scratchbot speed.
And then...
There you go.
Oh, there it is.
Let's try the bomb.
Oh, my God.
It was $200 billion.
I forgot how much it cost.
Oh, that was my bad.
I actually forgot how much they cost.
Oh, my God.
Let's check that out.
Not even worth my time.
Not even worth my fucking time.
Okay, maybe I can snake.
It is 0.1% chance.
I think it could be worth it.
Alright, I think it's time.
Alright, Mundo.
Go do my snake eyes.
I'm gonna check the snake eyes right now.
Alright, I should help them again.
Okay, I'm making more than I'm losing.
We had to help Mundo here.
And I need a no.
I need a no.
There we go.
Alright, Mundo.
Minus 25, Philly.
Oh, zero.
Zero.
65?
Okay.
Oh, it's zero.
Zero?
Okay.
65?
Okay, okay, we're positive now?
Oh, 84.
84?
Okay, there we go.
I... There you go.
Yeah, it's Nick, I said.
It's okay.
It's positive now.
We're at the positive now.
We're past the zeros, chat.
We're making the money.
Oh my god, Mondo speed.
Mondo can go faster.
I don't think I need Mondo to go faster.
He's actually going fast enough now for me.
I don't even need a scratch anymore.
It's just...
We just watch Mondo.
Go, Mondo, do your thing.
Keep on scratching, Mondo.
Keep on scratching.
Mondo is the streamer now.
I knew Mundo was a good investment.
He's so hungry.
He's eating faster than the bot could give him tickets.
Go, Mundo.
Now we're in idle game.
Mundo.
I knew I could count on you.
You know what?
Just for old times sake.
I'm in a tax bracket right now where I don't use my hands no
more like how dare you guys want me to do my own scratching
that's what Mundo is for that's where the dragon eats Mundo
is a dragon well thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it's passive income time Hands free Yeah, you want
me to use my own hands Like a fucking peasant?
Oh shit, it's time Goodbye, Mundo Goodbye We can't stop it
Like, I Just don't scratch this Goodbye, Mundo Wait Who was
great knowing you?
Give it to Mundo Oh wait, that's okay Mundo
We'll end it with Mundo We live by Mundo And end it with
Mundo Wait, wait, no I could Oh my god, wait, wait, I can't
I realized I realized Can I throw it away and then do
another final chance Until I hit it Time for Mundo to die Oh
my god, Mundo Don't claim it, Mando.
Mando, please don't!
Mando!
I really hoped it would work this time.
Mando shot you!
Mando, how could you do this?
I thought we were cool!
I thought we were tight like this!
Mundo just got a jackpot Mundo is in the will
It's time to pull out the big guns clean up this mess I've
got some phone calls to make We gotta grab the night Send
your tokens at the net market Let's see bundle free now live
by the bundle die by the bundle such is the life of a
gambler the bundle how could you do this to me
all right we got up yeah i was good thinking about the
jackpot upgrade too oh trashing when it gives three x xp i
mean sometimes i do that gently all right unlock bulk buying
for tickets start with a spell book when you think you got
mucho fundo don't forget you work for big mundo patch your
ass to thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
permanently unlocked after dying twice scratch bot starts
with a more capacity uh to keep it blowing longer 20 plus on
full scratched tickets.
Wait, I like that.
What the fuck would I need?
Oh, on day for every time it's leveled up.
Bro, I do day job like three times and now I'm good.
Manually, get that.
Plus 10% for each.
Completely unstatched symbol spot.
Nah, that's not as good.
Plus 15% for jackpots.
okay yeah we'll grab that we'll grab the jackpot we always
winning big bro scratchbot can wash plates now oh my god oh
start with no start with bundle
he's like you know you want to I take the mud outsource my
day job I can't afford him Mundo's too rich too rich for me
he suddenly he suddenly came up with a lot like walked into
a lot of money somehow I don't know how I don't know how he
came up with so much money respect until Mundo bring money
back somehow I don't know how he did it he was he was just
so rich all of a sudden
and Mundo all right one more one more run one more run oh my
god I go straight into it let's go I I just go straight into
it I don't even need my day job I just go straight into
they're just He's like, we know what you're here for.
We know what you're here for, Doki.
He goes straight in.
We're skipping the dishes now.
Literally.
No more danger for this bird.
I died and then I came back with Mundo.
Okay, oh my god go straight into I'm gonna grab I don't know
if this affects it now or not
I mean you get back oh yeah, I make my money back Oh my god
It's always so rough when you go come in with like none of
it none of the stuff Oh my god instantly jackpot Let's go
Oh, yeah, I should buy the trash, yeah.
I'll never have to use it.
All my winnings.
All my winnings are jackpots.
Oh, my God.
I don't know why I buy it.
It's like reflip muscle memory at that point.
Buying all of the tickets.
It's just muscle memory.
Yeah, but then I remember I have to place it one by one.
myself.
I got the apple tree.
Right off the bat.
Oh my god, we're speeding through this.
We're actually speeding through this.
Give me the fan!
Memories of another life.
I'm looping.
It's like attack on Titan.
I'm just looping it back.
Why am I fucking spending money on the two wins?
Put that in there.
Let him eat those.
Okay, we need maybe level 3.
I'll grab the tin coin just for it to be a bit faster.
Okay, nice jackpot.
Spoilers, bro!
I haven't unlocked Mundo yet.
He's so far away.
We're speedrunning.
running to the bomb very nice oh my god it's already we're
at quick cash now I'm actually doing a speed run it's like a
fucking speed run now I'm like reborn I play these games
before okay holy shit The two grand.
Can I afford the fan?
I don't even remember when it locks.
Oh my god, it's apple tree soon.
We already made it apple tree tier.
Oh my god.
I should put a speedrun timer right now.
We are at the apple tree.
Okay.
Okay, I need an aluminum coin or some shit.
Grab the luck.
All right, keep on eating.
Let's
go with an apple.
Easy, easy jackpot.
There we go.
We got the fan.
The 50 grand.
Wait, can I not afford?
Oh, I don't have enough yet.
Hey, apple tree.
Nice.
7,000.
Go with an apple.
Apple.
Easy money.
Alright, Apple, Apple.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
Feed him!
He must eat.
He's hungry.
Okay, we'll grab the speed, too.
Okay, Apple.
The fuck?
Okay, that's the beef.
Apple, apple, apple.
There we go.
We leveled up.
Unlock the sticky mat, but we don't need sticky mats.
We just need Mundo.
Get him in here!
He crazed more.
Okay.
Apple though
All right, apple, apple
Oh my god, look at all these apples though Doctors are gonna
be so scared of me Okay, uh Put more Yeah, I'll make sure
He's upgraded for Mundo
Yeah, I think I can grab I might be able to grab another
luck I'm gonna save for another luck Okay And then we'll do
quick cash.
And it's 20.
Scratch says.
I'll take the investment in that.
Okay, feed them.
Claim my money.
Claim my earnings.
Claim my passive income.
Who needs stock market when I have lottery tickets?
Oh my god, the luck.
It's quick cash time.
I'm ready for.
for the big boy leagues.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm ready for the big boy leagues.
Alright, numbers go up.
He wishes he was Mundo.
Yeah.
Yeah, we should be able to get quick cash now.
I will do quick cash.
There we go.
Yeah.
That's what I like to see.
And now I'm broke.
Not anymore, though.
I am broke.
It's alright.
That's two more quick cashes.
Okay.
Three.
23.
I'm best at many scratches.
I don't think we're ready for him to eat apple trees yet.
Do I have fan speed?
No, it's 250.
It's too slow.
Okay.
Nice.
Now I can't.
Oh, nope.
Nope.
Never mind.
Alright, now I can.
Alright.
It's time.
You're ready for the big boy meals now.
Okay, and I'm ready too.
Ah, shit.
All in.
All right.
Nice.
Good.
We don't do Lucky Cat yet.
Lucky Cat is reserved for level 7, I remember.
Lucky cat's a fucking bitch.
Not like his cooler brother that everyone loves.
Why can't you be more like Mundo, lucky cat?
Huh?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now we'll try one, lucky cat.
Why can't you be more like your brother?
you're useless in this family all right we do quick cash
still give the cat a chat he's trying his best okay not
trying hard enough nice okay we got another scratch luck.
All right, we need it.
All right.
Now we try Lucky Cat.
Don't want to take it.
There we go.
Well, not as much as I want you to be like 470.
There we go, Lucky Cat.
We learned our lesson.
All right, in here yeah that's fine it's like a hundred k
there we go now he's learned his lesson
it but he's just with the two flowers it's like it gives me
like a hundred k there we go
like i'll take the flowers
uh Oh, grab!
Stash strength, too.
Fuck it.
We have enough.
Would you make more money if you scratch everything off?
I'm lazy.
Laziness will always win.
Do I want $2 billion?
Or just not scratch everything?
God, choices are so hard.
It really is the hardest choice of my life.
Let's go.
See, look at that.
Being lazy paid off.
Oh, fuck it out.
I forgot to...
Oh, shit.
It's all right.
Countered each other.
See, this is why I don't scratch everything.
That's like, oh yeah, this is a speed run.
This is a...
We're on a speed run right now.
Okay, I think we're going to invest in Staten Dollars.
And then feed it to...
Feed it to Wilson.
Wilson!
Alright, Wilson.
It's time to eat.
I know you're hungry.
Alright.
Okay, Wilson needs to be strong.
stronger and then I might as well I can't afford it like
getting this you know let's go and we are speeding through
this though now his name is Mike oh it's the turtle I
fucking hate the turtle though
The tier one is so annoying.
Okay.
Get the speed.
I will just buy it just because.
Because I remember I had this.
Yeah.
Alright, you go over there.
I don't think we need the speed one.
Only because the fan speed.
Because I just feel it's not that worth it.
Alright, keep buying.
Keep screaming.
Scratching.
That 21 mil.
Keep scratching.
Never stop.
The grad never stop.
Pretty sure I have enough luck for this.
There we go.
259.
Mundo.
Mundo's back.
Guys, he's back.
Mundo, you came back for me after all this time.
I don't know what happened and how I died last time, but I
knew you were always there for me, Mundo.
He's back.
Mundo.
It's like he never left, guys.
The streamer's back, guys.
Now you can resubscribe.
Okay, I definitely need this.
Guys, you don't have to leave now.
He's back.
No trust Mundo.
What do you mean?
It's Mundo.
Can you move over?
You're too close to Mundo right now.
Don't worry, Mundo.
I helped you out, buddy.
Yeah, I definitely need more luck for the scratch my back.
I fucking hate that one, though.
I'll buy one, just for fun.
Oh, it's 13%.
How is that 13 if it's two out of two, four, six, seven?
Oh, my God, I'm not making shit back.
Fuck this.
Oh, sorry, Mundo.
Here, I'll let you do all the work for me.
Mundo came in.
Especially expensive car.
Yeah, because he invested properly, alright?
He invested in his earnings.
For passive income, guys.
How could you say that about Mundo?
Oh, buy a bunch and trash them all?
Oh, yeah.
Am I getting anything back?
I don't know, I got anything out of it.
Alright, let's grab more.
Alright, let's see this now.
8% chance this time.
It has less chance and I still get nothing.
I still get nothing.
Oh, they have to be scratched off.
All right.
Oh, oh,
I see.
Oh, never mind this matter.
Doesn't matter All right It's fine I got this though All
right, it's not fine no more
Oh nice jackpot
Oh, I did get a badge, you're right.
I hope you'll mind, though.
Okay, we're almost at more scratch luck, so I'll do one more
scratch my back.
I think the next scratch luck, I think it'd be worth it.
There we go.
All right, let me check 7%.
Okay, yeah, I think he's ready.
i think you're ready for the big boy the big boy meals
all right let's test our theory out i think he's ready get
that speed in mundo
there we go i'm all in i'm all in now claim all of these
it's turtle time all right I'm all in I'm watching this
let's see how this goes all right Mundo plus 1.5 billion oh
plus 1 billion 4 billion I knew I could count on you all
right more turtle soup more turtle soup for my little guy
Okay.
I'll help out.
There you go.
You know what?
I'll help out too.
I'll scratch with you.
Because we're a team.
Hey, that is actually we're getting a lot of the jackpots
now.
It's alright.
Counter the jackpot.
Alright.
The boss.
I think it's gonna be a while till I get to 244.
I just don't, I don't think this is worth it.
Okay, three, two, one.
Yeah, this, oh, I got, oh, oh, this is not right.
God damn it God fucking okay it's okay God you accidentally
it's okay I got too cocky ah fuck this let let them to do
this oh okay all right another one yeah let's go let's
fucking go i can be luckier now there we go
um this is a team effort it's a team game so mundo and i we
are both working very hard together guys as a team all right
mundo go faster now do it faster
I got you.
Alright, let's see if snake eyes.
And my luck has improved for snake eyes.
Alright, that's a 1.
A 2.
3.
6.
God damn it.
Still not worth it.
Still not worth taking snake eyes.
Okay, we need to create.
Mundo's speed.
No whammy, unfortunately.
I think we can increase our luck, though.
That's a minus $13 billion?
Whoops.
Looks like the market crashed.
Oopsie.
Just...
need one trillion one trillion that's all i need wait unless
unless my luck changes here oh wait four four four god
no kids why can't afford eggs
why why spend it on eggs where i could spend it on turtles
all right my window today is payday all right let's see can
i spend on anything and then more turtles more more turtles
okay we should have oh we can afford the luck now all right
now now we should be lucky enough for this.
Now it's time.
I think that doesn't need it.
A strong coin, though.
There we go.
Mundo is time.
It's time, Mundo.
We're introducing a new food, Wilson.
Damn it.
It's always the duds.
New food.
We're adding a new ingredient into your meal.
Oh, wait, I forgot that we don't need the turtles anymore.
I forgot about that.
Oopsie.
There we go.
Fives.
More five.
Five, five, five, five.
Let's go.
Is that another five?
Oh, my God.
This is another five and another five.
Let's go.
Okay, we should be able to afford.
Let's see.
Do I want Mundo's speed?
Actually, I want more luck.
I want to try the bomb again.
We need more luck for that.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna wait until we get the luck.
Zero.
Oh, oh, there you go.
$145 billion.
Just casually.
145 billion.
Yeah, this is easier than Bitcoin.
Guys, this is more reliable than cryptocurrency, guys.
It's just that easy.
One card, one ticket, 145 billion.
Just like that.
Kodokie, no.
Don't even need to scratch my fucking cards anymore Mundo's
got this These are Zimbabwe dollars Doki You take that back
I am a trillionaire How dare you
Buff 5-5.
5-5-5.
What the fuck?
75% fives and only get 1-5?
In this economy?
There we go.
That's what I like to see.
Lock up!
Keep going.
Never stop.
The grind never stop.
Yes!
Faster!
Scratchbot!
Alright, now we do the bomb.
Oh, wait.
I got two greens.
That's two trillion dollars.
Look at that.
Just like that.
Two trillion dollars.
Oh, yellow.
Oh, wait.
I thought that was a yellow, but that was just a green.
Get that shit out of here.
Yellow.
A 600 billion?
Oh, and that's one trillion dollars.
One trillion dollars.
So reliable.
Look at that.
Oh, my God.
Easiest jackpot of my fucking life.
Let's see.
strength, speed, uh, capacity, Mundo, Mundo go faster.
Mundo can go even faster.
And then...
Snake eyes.
I heard I'll be rich from a crazy bird woman.
I hate how much I invest in turkey.
To the moon!
Oh, it's to the moon.
Thank you for this Super chat, Ella.
Thank you.
Alright.
Now, we can do the bomb.
Is that?
That's yellow.
That's also yellow.
Okay, that's a bad one.
I'm still too... I'm too... 9% is a little bit too high
for...
Okay, that's yellow here.
Wait, there's two purplers, too.
It's a little bit too high to feed to Wilson and Mundo.
Oh, shit.
They're so hungry.
I'm so sorry.
I was too busy scratching the bomb.
I forgot to beat them.
There you go.
Whoops.
I mean, real time's sake.
Let's see.
There's nothing?
Oh, there was nothing.
Okay, we got purple and yellow here.
All right, nice.
Oh, nice.
It's fine.
I'll let you in on a little secret.
We have some special scratchouts.
We're big sp- That's me!
Oh, my God!
I get promoted!
To spend more money!
Let's go!
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm a VIP.
That's right.
huh I'm very important yeah I'm pretty important person
I think no okay I'm gonna get one more luck up before we put
the bomb in there yeah thank god I did that was would have
been two trillion god oh god I almost actually scratched it
I was like yep they got in scratch Anyway, let me scratch
this real quick.
105%?
Okay, there we go.
All right, now we put the bomb in there.
I think I have enough money now to invest in this.
All right.
Let's see how this goes.
Plus 5, plus 4 trillion, plus 7 trillion, plus 4 trillion.
What?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, let's go.
Oh, mine is.
It's okay.
We win more than we lose.
So it, like, pays itself off.
Okay.
Mundo can be faster.
Mundo can always be faster.
Alright, 200 trillion.
Alright.
I'm actually a little worried to try it.
bank break.
It's sort of my entire life savings.
So I think I'm going to wait until the luck is higher.
I'm going to wait until it's a little higher.
Sort of, you know, all my money in my bank account from my
20 offshore bank accounts.
Yeah, I make it a little faster.
I'm automating the system now.
Oh, it's this.
We need the yellow here.
Oh, Oh shit.
All right, there we go.
Buy one just to look at.
I shall wield this to my dragon.
I put it on display for the one time.
I used my entire life savings.
We have tried everything, even dark magic.
And though we never succeed, we did turn into a product.
Now you can use magic to- Magic!
Oh my God!
use magic now?
How the fuck do I use magic?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I could decorate my stuff.
Why the fuck would I use that when I could upgrade?
Wait, I spent
my money.
Money.
My...
I...
I better oh my god that's it That's it
My money
Like why would I use that oh my god it's for bank break
isn't it This is a bank break shit isn't it guys
That's it alright Let's try this out.
Oh yeah, fuck that.
51 trillion.
Really?
That is all I'm worth.
All right, one more time.
Okay.
All right, that's a lot better.
That's a lot better.
I'll wait for the cool down.
That's right
All right, let's get
I'll get another luck and then I'll spend it on speed and
strength
Let's put all this in here Get that bomb in Okay
There we go I'm not spending money on fucking coins.
I have I literally can use magic now.
We're almost there.
Coins are for fucking peasants.
My chauffeur use a coin.
I use magic.
And I got nothing.
I got nothing.
And it's got.
Isn't using magic cheating?
How else do you think the Rich stays rich.
That's what the poor was saying.
Alright, let's see.
Magic.
Alright, there you go.
$100 trillion.
Just like that.
We're under the thumb of Big One.
How rich are conjuring gold?
out from dark magic.
Who led a coin scratcher in my office?
Bring him!
Take that guy away!
He's lowering the property value of my scratch cards.
I have been, I spent three hours just scratching lottery
tickets.
I do not have a problem.
115 trillion Oh shit It's I don't know if it's worth it
Because like I only earned 215 trillion But like I spent 200
trillion on it So I'm just gonna Spend it on the bomb still
I don't think it's worth it And I'll invest in the Speed and
strength And Mundo Then Mundo have a turn
oh there was no negative magic oh that's right you can win
the Mona Lisa with my in the scratch cards I'm scratching
now you can win the fucking Mona Lisa
holy shit and and and
It's not a scam, by the way.
I don't buy an island.
I win an island.
Yeah.
It's like you don't even understand.
It's like we're not the same.
What happened to magic?
you know sometimes i want to be real you know oh my you know
i need to remember where i came from you know like just to
like hang out with the people too
all right scratch that for me all right more luck
i don't think mando needs to be faster he's doing like he's
doing it at the same speed I was with Wilson.
You changed, Jokey.
I'm not upgrading my coins in so long.
Why use coins?
When I can just go out of Kazam!
Look at that.
Put more scratch bot speed.
Yeah, Mundo is still catching up, so I don't think Mundo
cares.
Mundo's so fast.
You know what?
You have a loyal customer for so long.
I'm going to offer you a subscription bot to help you buy
tickets.
Oh my, finally, I don't have to use fingers anymore.
I...
Fucking finally.
God, I have to use my fucking fingers.
Like the poor.
It's a new world.
And again, finally, like a peasant.
Even less work.
The money is getting to her hair.
And automate everything.
Alright, alright, subscription bot.
Buy me my tickets!
Get it, Kite!
Yes!
Keep buying!
What's next?
The fan starts moving by itself?
I need him to buy faster.
The satisfactory.
No!
must be faster
powercraft alright what the fuck is 1.00T these are like
we're at like imaginary number territory now alright let's
do x-mix countdown magic okay I don't know if that was worth
it use magic again 4.0 oh yeah it's not worth it i'm losing
money here i'm losing my time is money unlocked thrift store
is that quintillion oh my god am i quintillion there now
oh a new card yeah but like i don't even screen i even use
magic for this That's too...
That's too many.
I don't even scratch one no more.
Okay, maybe I should upgrade my fan speed.
It's like...
It's been so long since I've upgraded it.
There we go.
I didn't think I needed it before.
Okay, we can get another luck and then we'll try our hand.
Oh my god, this is a lot faster now.
all right 477 we can wait we're almost at 477
i want to just grab the left part of the zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero one percent so you're just more wealth
than the entire earth cat bro borrow a few billion fellow
canuck thank you for the super chat thank you thank you guys
i know we're talking about i don't have that much money guys
it's all in investments guys i got it's not on me it's not i
don't have that much money on me guys i it's all in like uh
stocks and all right nice okay i think it's worth the
christmas now one now not
very yeah yeah i don't have any liquid assets on me guys
guys i'm just I'm conceptually wealthy
Okay, we'll have him buy the Christmas one now I think I can
afford the Christmas one
23 Oh yeah, 100% I can afford it I took it like to order a
single two win scratchy please Okay, wait, it's been so long
since I've seen it Alright, don't worry, sir Make sure you
win Oh, I'm so sorry SP.
I'm so sorry.
That was not a winner.
You tried your luck, but maybe you just gotta try again.
SP.
Thank you, the super chap.
Thank you.
Yeah, we do.
I need to wait.
Like, I'm almost there for it, though.
There we go.
Buy faster.
Yes!
Alright, Mundo actually needs to be faster now for me.
Keep buying.
Keep fighting, Mondo.
Aw, shucks.
It's so unfortunate that I wasn't a big ticket winner.
Okay, we just wait.
Mondo is fast enough now.
We can make him faster.
Alright, here we go.
Even faster.
Even faster!
all right just need two point something so i can where i can
buy even faster too all right more scratch luck all right
now i don't think we can try the thrift store yet i think we
need another more scratch luck for that so i'm investing
more on xmas
okay let's see
Let's get Scratchbot speed.
Just to automate it faster.
Alright, well, we'll check out Thrift Store.
Let's check it out.
Matt!
I'm too weak.
No.
There's no way.
What do you mean?
No.
Oh.
I'm so weak.
No!
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
That's right.
I got thrift.
I still think we need more luck.
I'm pretty sure.
For this one.
Test your strength.
It's coated with diamond now.
It's...
Magic!
Try again.
1.6.
Okay, yeah, I won, like, half.
I don't know if I should invest in thrift store, though.
Oh.
That's right.
It's time.
It's time for thrift store.
Oh.
I shall invest in thrift store faster buy faster even faster
yes keep buying okay and claim this claim that
Oh, hey.
Alright, it's fine.
59.
Oh, I can be even luckier.
Luck time.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think Mundo is fast enough right now.
Alright, let's see.
I'm not scratching it myself.
What do they think?
Who do you think I am?
They didn't even know who they're talking to.
I don't scratch my own cards.
It's a pot game.
Do they know who they're talking to?
Does Mundo receive any work benefits?
Mundo scratch.
Mundo knows what they do.
He doesn't need to be asked any questions.
Okay.
Minus 80.
I am not.
Okay.
It's not as lucky as I thought it'd be.
All right.
There we go.
It's getting better now.
It's not minus, minus, minus, minus, minus, minus.
Minus, minus.
I was like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute here.
I might have messed up.
I might have to go in.
Okay,
this is not...
Okay, I'm stuck at...
Mundo, stop.
Wait, stop.
We gotta go back to Christmas.
We got...
We got it.
We about to go back to Christmas.
Mundo...
Mundo, stop.
This is not as...
Alright, we go back to Christmas.
I will get rid of the...
We'll get rid of all the...
All the other ones.
But...
Mendo went wild there.
Mendo might have been pocketing some money.
Alright, we gotta get to 298.
It's not increasing, guys.
Alright, there we go.
up we just wait now we just gotta wait i need to get that
luck up wow mando how are you able to afford such a
five-star hotel vacation with your family mando that's
pretty weird
hmm mando okay now we go back to the thrift store there we
go now i I trust.
I trust the system now.
Well, should I have enough luck for the thrift store?
Yeah, we definitely do.
Alright.
All in on thrift store again.
Oh, there we go.
Alright, give me a six ton millionaire.
Oh.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Here we go.
Oh.
Wait, what's that?
It's okay.
As long as I don't scratch it.
Wait, can I actually just throw it away?
I just throw it away?
Oh, shit.
My trash can.
Alright, here we go again.
Dispose it.
It's okay.
I can buy another trash can.
Oh, that was my last one.
Oh, that's awkward.
Did you kill your trash can?
All right, Mundo.
You'll tank it for me, right, Mundo?
It's okay.
It's a murder suicide.
They'll never know.
We've done it.
I don't know.
We're still pretty far off.
We didn't think to suggest that.
It was the trash can.
We should burn through the entire world.
We're getting a map to get research to green light to
experiment.
All right, let's discuss when you return.
Get rid of the corpse and get back here ASAP.
Get rid of the Mundo corpse.
Will do sick.
They'll never know.
Oh, wait.
Mundo died for your green.
Oh, that was fun.
I can't believe I played three hours of just scratching
tickets.
That's looking wild.
I
Well, anyway, I thought it would be a shorter stream, but I
got way too invested.
I got way too invested in the scratchy scratch.
Deriv, thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank
you.
I like spending my money today, and I spent on you since I
made a poorly made video game on getting your skin in Apex.
Now take my money, you Greedy bird.
Thank you for the gentle soup, but they can thank you.
Oh, we're sending Miranda poorly made video.
Oh, really?
Oh, that's cool.
Yeah, they can give the magenta soup, but they can thank
you.
Hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
I gotta go back to doing behind the scenes work.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it um i i forgot i made my i forgot tomorrow i have to be up
at 12 30.
so that's the that's the biggest challenge we're gonna have
this week i i scheduled one 12 30 stream so so i hope i hope
i go to bed today um anyway guys i'll see you guys next time
everyone Bye, everybody.
Bye.
Also, sorry.
It's thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Damn, the IRS got fun, though.
Anyway, bye, everybody.
Bye, bye.